Wann kann ich euch jetzt dann in der großen Hollywood-Produktion mit, ja ich weiß jetzt grad gar nicht, wie man sich da als Vater und wie man sich als Sohn wünschen könnte. Hast du schon mal Gedanken darüber gemacht, wer spielen soll?
Nein, ich kenne aber auch keine Schauspieler. Also wann, ich würde sagen in zwei Jahren vielleicht, vielleicht auch weniger.
Ich will meinen Lieblingsverein. Okay, ich fahre am Wochenende mit dir ins Stadion, wir gucken ein paar Spiele und als Gegenleistung lässt du dich in der Schule nicht mehr so provozieren.
Erste, zweite und dritte Liga, das sind 56 Vereine, die schauen wir uns alle zusammen an.
Wie, 56?
Es ist vier Jahre her, im Juli 2019, da haben wir uns zuletzt getroffen und wir haben uns sogar hier getroffen, hier in München. Ich freue mich sehr, dass bei mir sind die Wochenendrebellen, Mirco von Juterczenka und Jason von Juterczenka. Hallo ihr beiden. Ja, gleich müssen wir dieses Intro noch nachbesprechen, aber erst müssen wir gute Gastgeber sein, wollen wir gute Gastgeber sein. Und Andreas Thies hier begrüßen, endlich ist er mal im Rasenfunk, unglaublich wie lange das gedauert hat. Hallo Andreas, schön, dass du da bist.
Weil ja auch die Diagnose im echten Leben nicht optimal verlief.
Ja, und erstens das und zweitens gab es eigentlich eine Vermischung von zwei Situationen. Denn wir haben nicht nur ein Diagnosegespräch, wir hatten eigentlich zwei Diagnosegespräche, weil wir haben zu dem Zeitpunkt noch hier in München gelebt. Und der Erstkontakt war mit jemanden von der Caritas, die Jason begleitet hat im Kindergarten etc. und die gesagt hat, ich gehe davon aus, dass ihr Sohn Aspergerhaut ist, ich darf aber gar nicht diagnostizieren. Und wir haben dann Kontakt aufgenommen zum Hexer Klinikum hier in München, die die Diagnostik machen. Gut, das ist aber dann halt, da vergehen halt erst mal sechs Monate. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass du eine Woche später dahingehst und dann sagst du ja, alles klar, das passt so, sondern das war sechs Monate. Und diese beiden Gespräche waren sehr unterschiedlich. Das Caritas-Gespräch war sehr einfühlsam und vorsichtig und sehr empathisch, während das Diagnosgespräch schon sehr bar und sehr hart war. Und nach der dritten Nachfrage dann irgendwo so endete mit, sie werden sich damit abfinden müssen, dass ihr Sohn behindert ist. Und es viele Dinge gibt, die er nicht schaffen kann. Und meine Frau fragte dann ja, was bedeutet das schulisch so? Ja gut, der wird wahrscheinlich auf eine Förderschule gehen insgesamt. Also das war schon sehr barsch und sehr, sehr absolut irgendwie, wie das dann auch von einem Experten entgegengebracht wird. Und das war natürlich auch etwas, was wir nie vergessen haben und auch gerne in den Film transportiert hätten, sodass Jason eigentlich so die Vorgabe gemacht hat und sagt, es muss mit rein, dass Autismus nicht heilbar ist, weil das immer wieder ein Thema ist. Es muss mit rein, dass es ein Spektrum ist. Und so haben die dann diese Diagnoseszene et cetera so gebaut, dass das dann so ein Mix aus beiden ist und einigermaßen klar ist, was los ist.
Also quasi möglichst nah an der Realität, aber noch mit einem pädagogischen Auftrag.
Ja, das war der Wunsch, dem auch nachgekommen wurde und der wirklich gut gelungen ist.
Andreas, darüber haben wir ja auch gesprochen, viel nach dem Film, weil das logischerweise auch etwas ist, wo sowas sehr schnell kippen kann. Und da werden verschiedene Techniken angewandt, ohne dass ich da jetzt spoilere. Da gibt es Montagen, es gibt natürlich Tonkulissen, die verwendet werden, schnelle Schnitte hintereinander. Uns beide hat das sehr bewegt, glaube ich. Also wir sind nicht neutral aus diesem Film herausgegangen, so sehr wir uns darüber gefreut haben, deine Pullover und deine Jacke wieder zu erkennen. Und auch Jason, es war irgendwie toll, dich nochmal in Jung zu erleben. Aber das war für uns auch ein wichtiges Thema. Was ist dir davon noch in Erinnerung geblieben? Und wie bist du jetzt auch, ich meine, wir haben es jetzt vor einer ganzen Weile schon gesehen im Nachhinein mit der Darstellung, ja zufrieden ist das falsche Wort, aber was hat es bei dir hinterlassen?
Na also bei mir hat es dann, ich kann das halt wirklich jetzt nur als Zuschauer nachvollziehen bzw. kann das nur darstellen, aber mich hat es sehr zufrieden zurückgelassen. Ich habe ja in den Jahren, wo ich das Blog schon verfolgt habe und wo ich dann auch Mirco kennen gelernt habe und auch Jason kennen gelernt habe, habe ich ja schon sehr viel über Autismus gelernt. Ich habe eben noch mal nachgeguckt, während ihr gesprochen habt, Autismus in Filmen, wie er behandelt worden ist bzw. wie ich ihn dann schon mal gesehen habe, berühmtester Film, vielleicht dann auch Rain Man und so. Aber diese ganze Geschichte rundum, das ist ein Spektrum und das sind verschiedene Ausprägungen. Da habe ich lange gebraucht, um das dann auch zu lernen. Das habe ich dann über den Podcast über das Blog und dann auch über das Buch kennengelernt. Und das sollte dann mit Nachdruck nochmal gebracht werden. Erstens, das ist keine Clowns-Veranstaltung hier, sondern das ist jetzt nicht der Guckenweih in irgendeiner Weise witzig drüber, sondern wir wollen das möglichst ernsthaft drüber bringen, sodass dann auch wirklich alle es verstehen. Und dass das dann wirklich eine Ausprägung ist und dass es dann ein Spektrum ist. Und das, finde ich, hat dieser Film extrem gut rübergebracht. Und ich finde auch, dass er das mit Nachdruck rübergebracht hat, weil ja diese Erklärungsszene dann am Anfang ist, mit diesem Gespräch dann auch. Und da habe ich das Kino dann auch wieder sehr zufrieden verlassen, weil das, was ich gelernt habe über die Jahre, ist dann ja auch nochmal kurz runtergedampft auf ein paar Minuten, ist das sehr gut rübergebracht worden. Und dass gleich so ein bisschen der Wind aus den Segeln genommen wird, das ist hier keine Komödie. Und dann wird es nicht auf die Schippe genommen, sondern das ist hier ein ernsthaftes Thema. Und das wird so ernsthaft wie möglich und so seriös wie möglich angegangen.
Das ist ein sehr wahrhaftiger Anspruch, den der Film an die Realität und an seine Geschichte hat. Das war auch so mein Eindruck. Und dazu gehört hier auch die Art und Weise, wie sowohl dann du im, also dein Film, ich, mit dieser Situation umgeht und natürlich auch die ganze Reise. Wir wollen jetzt hier nicht spoilern, aber das ist auch nochmal eine interessante Frage gewesen, die du, Floy, an David Fitts gestellt hast, an Andreas, was man denn dann mitnimmt aus einem solchen Film. Und da fand ich seine Antwort sehr interessant.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Mirco dir wirklich ein Learning geben kann. Also vieles auch einfach tatsächlich aushalten. Weil, na klar, die Leute im Bordrestaurant, oft genug passiert es hier, dass einfach verzogene Kinder rumschreien, die Eltern rumschicken und du sagst natürlich, Alter, was ist los? Ja, ist genau wie du sagst. Wenn dann jemand sagt, übrigens hier ist die Diagnose, das ist bitte kurz Verständnis, dann ist es was anderes. Also man muss natürlich auch die anderen Leute verstehen, weil man wäre selber ja wahrscheinlich eher auf der Seite der Leute im Bräutbestro, dass man sagt, weil man hat es ja ein paar Mal erlebt und man hat nicht jedes Mal so reagiert, vielleicht ist er ja auf dem Spektrum und deswegen hat er, also das ist nicht das erste, was du denkst und dass eine Mutter dann zu dir sagt, mein Kind ist übrigens, bla bla bla, xy, na klar, ihr Kind ist alles, was sie wollen, weißt du? Es ist so simpel ist es nicht, es ist einfach auch unfassbar nervig. Insofern glaube ich, es gibt diese einfache Handhabe nicht. Ich verstehe auch die Leute und Mirco ist der Letzte, der die Leute nicht versteht, weil er sagt, es gab Momente, wo er ihn einfach erwürgen will und ich glaube auch das muss man sich zugestehen, sonst laufen alle so pärzlich und heilig und humorlos rum. Ich glaube, die einzige Waffe und das macht Mirco halt super, ist auch Humor, damit umzugehen. Das ist einfach mal kacke, es ist missverständlich, es ist mühsam, es ist super peinlich, wenn dein Kind dir da so rum ins Essen spuckt und sagt, da frisst meine Reste und du bist so ja, natürlich Meister, ich esse die Reste, damit es hier jetzt keinen Aufstand gibt. Das ist halt kacke, aber es ist auch sehr interessant und was du sagst ist ja, Mirco hat es ja geschafft, durch diesen Humor und durch diese Story mit den Vereinen, die Leute dafür zu interessieren, sich in dieses Leben mal rein zu begeben. Und das ist einfach spannend, mehr muss es auch gar nicht sein.
Mehr muss es vielleicht gar nicht sein, Mirco.
Klingt ganz einfach eigentlich, ne?
Dafür hat er eine Minute gebraucht, wenn man so den Podcast machen sollte.
Nein, hat er recht, hat er aber auch gut zusammengefasst in vielen Bereichen. Ja, nein, absolut, das passt. Es ist halt immer nicht so ganz einfach, auf Basis von einzelnen Szenen dort die große Geschichte aufzumachen, aber Florian hat das sehr schnell geschafft, mir zu erklären, wie er die Situation oder wie er seine Mirco-Perspektive so wahrnimmt. Okay, du bist so dieser berufliche Problemlöser dort und willst da alles regeln und musst da alles regeln und zu Hause gibt es immer eine Situation, die kriegst du nicht so richtig geregelt und das passte, das war fein und hat das gut zusammengefasst.
Und Jason, wie denkst du darüber, wenn du das hörst, weil da ja auch, da haben wir schon mal indirekt im Tribünengespräch damals auch schon darüber gesprochen, immer wieder in den Texten, die erst im Blog erschienen sind und dann im Buch, wurde ja auch dadurch, dass Mirco das humorvoll verarbeitet hat, aber auch sehr ehrlich, da sind auch manchmal harte Sätze über dich gefallen und hier war er jetzt auch gerade, am liebsten hätte er ihn manchmal erwirkt, also natürlich nicht physisch, sondern im übertragenen Sinn. Aber wie ist das für dich, wenn du das so hörst?
Naja, ich widerspreche da natürlich an manchen Stellen, so was ich das anders sehe. Ich bin auch der Meinung, man kann von meinen Mitmenschen abverlangen, dass sie sich kein vorschnelles Urteil bilden, sondern selbst wenn sie nicht wissen, dass ich auf dem Spektrum bin, kann man grundsätzlich allen Menschen mit der Einstellung begegnen, dass man es ja nicht weiß, dass man die Ursache für das, was man dort gerade erlebt, ja nicht kennt und deswegen keine voreiligen Schlüsse zieht. Das ist nicht die Realität, das weiß ich ja selber, aber ich finde, das kann man durchaus von Menschen verlangen, deswegen kann man auch das Verhalten von diesen Menschen im Broadbistro oder an der Bushaltestelle kritisieren, meiner Meinung nach. Also die verhalten sich falsch, aber es ist ja trotzdem in der Realität so. So reagieren halt die meisten Menschen und ja, das mag dann so sein. Ich kann Papst ja nicht in seiner Wahrnehmung widersprechen. Für ihn war das dann so, für ihn war das dann peinlich vielleicht oder unangenehm auf jeden Fall. Ich sehe da nirgendswo meine Schuld, aber das hat er dann ja auch in der Regel nicht geschrieben. Also klar, an manchen Stellen sind wir uns auch uneinig über die Schuldfrage, aber wir sind uns eher selten uneinig über die Schuldfrage, sondern meistens sind es einfach halt unangenehme Situationen, die für Papst die unangenehm sind, an denen ich dann aber auch leider nichts ändern kann und dementsprechend fühle ich mich da auch nicht verantwortlich.
Ich glaube, da muss man aber auch so ein bisschen zwei Perspektiven unterscheiden. Einmal die Perspektive so auf unser Umfeld, wenn wir untereinander unterwegs sind, also wenn wir jetzt die Bord-Bistro-Szene als Beispiel nehmen, dann ist mir das natürlich unangenehm so, wenn du da so, also das wird sich auch nicht ändern lassen. Ich kann aber nachvollziehen, dass das für dich nicht so ist.
Mir war die auch unangenehm tatsächlich.
Okay. Was aber eine zweite Perspektive ist, ist so dieser Umgang von uns beiden miteinander auch so in seiner, in der Härte, die wir manchmal pflegen. Und ich glaube da, das wäre so die zweite Szene, wo Florian und ich auch so ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen unterschiedlicher Meinung war. Doch, will ich sagen, wir waren da unterschiedlicher Meinung. Das ist, wo ich an einer Stelle zu Jason sage, also im Film zu Jason sage, dass mir die Arbeit wichtiger ist als er. Und das eigentlich aus einer wirklich auch mit einem kurzen Moment des Überlegens, also nicht so rein aus dem Effekt. Okay, ja, in der Szene geht es ihm auch gerade nicht so ganz gut. Er hat da eine harte Zeit hinter sich. Aber das ist so der, so ein bisschen das, wo sich vielleicht zwischen Real-Wochenend-Rebellen und Film-Wochenend-Rebellen auch so ein bisschen aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen die Wege trennen. Wenn es bei uns zwischen uns eskaliert, dann ist das etwas, wo auch die Überforderung von beiden Seiten irgendwie so der Auslöser des ganzen ist. Denn es wird dann sehr, sehr barisch, sehr, sehr hart manchmal. Und da fallen dann auch Worte, die zum Glück, egal von wem sie kommen, auch kurze Zeit später wieder vergessen sind. Aber es ist nicht so dieses Kurz-Überlegen und dann so, ja eigentlich finde ich dich ganz schön scheiße. Das kam so in der Form nie vor und auch nicht, dass es eine Situation gab, wo ich auch nur eine Sekunde darüber nachgedacht habe, ob mir meine Arbeit tatsächlich wichtiger ist als mein Sohn. Es ist im Film natürlich so dieses, und das kann ich wieder nachvollziehen, und das will ich auch gar nicht ganz von der Hand weisen, diese Flucht in die Arbeit manchmal so, dass die natürlich damit so ein bisschen gestärkt werden soll, die sicherlich auch mal da war, die aber sicherlich in unserem realen Leben nicht so der Hauptantrieb des Ganzen war. Das sind glaube ich so diese beiden Blickwinkel, die sich da irgendwo vereinen.
Jason, weil du es eben gesagt hast, die Boardbistro-Szene, die war dir auch unangenehm. Gibt es Situationen dann heute noch, du hast Regeln aufgestellt oder ihr habt Regeln aufgestellt, dann ja auch in der Familie, gibt es Situationen dann heute noch, wo du sagst, das ist mir jetzt unangenehm, aber wir müssen da jetzt durch? Oder sind diese Regeln jetzt so fest installiert, dass du sagst, das ist halt so jetzt und für wen es unangenehm ist, ist mir egal, das machen wir jetzt so? Oder gibt es wirklich dann auch Szenen im täglichen Leben, die dir dann auch noch unangenehm sind?
Ach so, nicht, dass dann ein Missverständnis auftaucht. Mir war die Boardbistro-Szene nicht unangenehm, weil sie in der Öffentlichkeit stattfand. Mir war die Boardbistro-Szene unangenehm aus offensichtlichen Gründen, weil das Problem nicht gelöst werden konnte, weil das Essen am Ende verschwendet wurde. Also das Problem wäre für mich nicht größer gewesen, wenn es bei uns im Wohnzimmer stattgefunden hätte. Und es haben auch vergleichbare Situationen mit uns im Wohnzimmer stattgefunden. Aber nein, es gibt nichts, also es gibt eigentlich keine Situationen oder Eskalationen so, wo ich mich sage, da schäne ich mich für uns der Öffentlichkeit gegenüber, weil wir da total eskalieren oder so, sondern es hat dann halt auch seine Gründe. Und ich, wie gesagt, die Bordmistros-Szenen zum Beispiel, dafür könnte ich mir, also ich kann es sowieso nicht, aber es wäre auch total unsinnig, dafür irgendwie meinen Vorwurf zu machen, weil diese Szene vorbestimmt war, ja. Es konnte in dem Moment, wo diese Nudeln mit der Soße drauf kamen, war diese gesamte Situation vorbestimmt. Es konnte gar nichts anderes mehr passieren als diese Eskalation, weil durch die faktischen Bedingungen eigentlich alles bereits determiniert war. Und so ist das häufig. Und die Regeln, die wir heute haben, hinter den Regeln stehe ich ja auch. Ich meine, wir haben die Familienvereinbarung zu Hause, die ja im Film auch gezeigt wird, aber deutlich, deutlich vereinfacht der Realität gegenüber. Also die reale Familienvereinbarung ist erstens strenger. Auch die Regel, dass kein Essen entsorgt wird, diese Ausnahmen, die da gestellt werden, die gibt es so gar nicht. Also die Regeln sind viel strenger, als sie im Film gezeigt werden teilweise. Und komplexer. Aber hinter den Regeln stehe ich auch. Und sie auch dann in der Öffentlichkeit zu vertreten und in der Öffentlichkeit auch umzusetzen. Das ist ja erstens meine verfassungsmäßige Pflicht als Vorsitzender, der ich auch nachkommen muss.
Du bist Vorsitzender des Familienrats? War das das letzte Mal auch schon, seit wir vor vielen Jahren gekommen sind?
Ich hatte mich zwar...
Nee, einmal in Jahren wird gewählt.
Ich hatte mich zwar beim letzten Mal auch zur Wahl gestellt, aber...
Genau richtig, du hast dann deine Schäster für dich gewinnen können.
Und dementsprechend muss ich diese Regeln natürlich auch umsetzen, aber ich will sie auch umsetzen. Und nein, es ist mir nicht unangenehm, sie umzusetzen, auch in der Öffentlichkeit nicht, sondern die sind so.
Eine Sache noch zum Bordbistro. Wenn die Leute, die im Bordbistro mit euch dort drin saßen damals, wenn die diesen Film sehen, sie werden ganz genau wissen, wo sie zu dem Zeitpunkt waren, als die Bordbistro-Szene entstand. Weil das ist eine Szene, die, wenn ich sie im Bordbistro erlebt hätte, die ich bis ans Ende meiner Tage erzählen würde. Und da bin ich mir sicher, da werden zwei oder drei Menschen, die im Bordbistro damals saßen, die werden in diesem Film sitzen, vielleicht und denken, Moment, Moment, Moment, das bin ja ich.
Das ist sehr gut möglich, ja. Wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, in den letzten zehn Tagen schon 15 Anfragen vom VfR am bekommen. Aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen. Fanverein, der größte Blog, ich bin Anhänger, ich bin seit 30 Jahren dort. Von daher kann gut sein, dass auch da noch über die Kinoebene noch was passiert.
Aber hat sich Jimbo's Autowäsche auch gemeldet?
Die haben sich tatsächlich noch nicht gemeldet. Und da ist es sogar noch skurriler. Die haben wir nämlich sogar mal aktiv angeschrieben, weil wir dort eigentlich gerne auf der Lesereise unsere letzte Benefizlesung machen wollten. So einfach so vor dieser Autowäsche. Aber die haben sich tatsächlich nicht gemeldet.
Wahrscheinlich dachten wir, es wäre ein Scherz.
Ja, das könnte sein.
Da kennen sie euch schlecht, kann man dazu nur sagen. Aber wie ist denn das, wenn man so an einem Drehbuch arbeitet und quasi an der Fiktionalisierung der eigenen Charaktere arbeitet und dann eben auch solche Streitszenen zum Beispiel hat? Jason, denkst du jetzt manchmal anders über Konflikte, die ihr miteinander habt, weil du diese Außenperspektive jetzt ja viel häufiger einnehmen musstest in den letzten Monaten?
Ja, also über meine Reaktion denke ich eigentlich nicht anders. Aber mir ist dann schon klar, dass, wenn man diesen Streit dann mal nüchtern analysiert, ist mir natürlich auch klar, dass man nicht in allen Situationen Papsi die Schuld trägt. Was? Ja.
Was ist denn mit dir los?
Wir haben gerade einen der schönsten Momente in deinem Leben.
Jetzt habe ich mehr Gänsehaut als bei der Kinofremiere. Wirklich?
Also bei der Nudelszene zum Beispiel. Das war einfach eine Situation, die war durch die Fakten, so wie sie waren, so vorbestimmt. Da hätte niemand von uns irgendwas dran ändern können. Dass Papsi mich dann dort raussehrt, war natürlich die schlechteste mögliche Reaktion von allen. Aber selbst eine beste Reaktion hätte die Eskalation nicht verhindern können. Also insofern kann man, wenn man diese Streitsituation dann nüchtern analysiert, dann fällt es natürlich viel leichter zu sehen, okay, da hätte niemand was anderes machen können oder da trägt genau, da trägt die Person die Schuld. Da sind es die Fakten, die das einfach so vorbestimmt haben. Also da lassen sich die Streit natürlich noch mal anders analysieren. Aber rückwirkend gab es jetzt auch keinen Streit, den ich mir dann rückblickend angeguckt habe, wo ich sage, ja, also der war eigentlich, den hätte man so vermeiden können. Der war komplett unsinnig, da habe ich überreagiert oder so. Das kann ich rückblickend eigentlich nicht erkennen. Also ja, man blickt auf viele Streits noch mal anders. Aber ich denke, die Streitsituationen hatten in der Regel auch meinerseits aus einem guten Grund. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass ich einfach diese Szenen, die dort im Film gezeigt werden, sind ja keine Wutausbrüche. Ich glaube, es wird kein einziger klassischer Wutausbruch gezeigt, die es ja auch gibt. Also einfach Wutausbrüche, Situationen, in denen ich irgendwie meinen Willen nicht bekomme und dann halt meine Umgebung bestrafe, indem ich halt ausraste. Und dann muss man irgendwie nachgeben oder verhandeln, um das zu beenden. Das gibt es ja auch, aber das wird im Film eigentlich nicht gezeigt. Sondern die Eskalationen, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht komplett irre, also eigentlich alle, die im Film gezeigt werden, sind wirklich Overloads. Und die haben immer einen guten Grund. Also die haben immer, die geschehen nicht von alleine, sondern die geschehen, weil sich irgendwas in der Umgebung so verhält, dass ich damit nicht zurechtkomme, dass ich damit nicht klarkomme und dass ich davon befordert werde. Und dementsprechend kann auch ich dort für diese Situation nichts. Es ist nicht so, dass ich diese Eskalationen bewusst eingesetzt habe, um einen Willen zu bekommen. Ich habe auch immer bewusst Eskalationen eingesetzt, um einen Willen zu bekommen, aber nicht in diesen Situationen.
Aber es ist ja eigentlich dann auch eine Stärke, was du eben gesagt hast, wenn man die Situation und den Streit nüchtern analysiert. Gelingt ja auch nicht jedem, einen Streit anschließend nüchtern zu analysieren, beziehungsweise braucht es dann ja auch so ein bisschen. Und ist das dann vielleicht auch so eine Stärke, dass wenn man die Konflikte hat und wenn man, ihr habt es erzählt, dass es zwischendurch richtig kracht, dass man dann irgendwann dann auch in die nüchternen Analyse gehen kann? Weil, das kann ich von mir aus zugeben, das gelingt mir nicht immer bei Streitereien mit Familienmitgliedern, in die nüchternen Analyse zu gehen.
Das geht bei uns eigentlich immer relativ schnell. Also manchmal noch am selben Tag bei so kleineren Sachen, würde ich sagen. Wobei kleinere Sachen nicht heißen, dass die Streit weniger intensiv sind, sondern dass die Ursache eigentlich Kleinigkeiten waren. Und der Streit hauptsächlich dadurch eskalieren konnte, dass einer von uns halt eine extrem kurze Zündschnur hatte. Oder manchmal auch beide gleichzeitig. Also ich sag mal, letztes Jahr hat es ausgereicht, dass ich in einem rumänischen Zug nicht rechtzeitig zur Seite gegangen bin, als jemand kam. Dass Papsi mich mit übelsten Schimpfwörtern, also FSK 18 Schimpfwörtern, durch diesen ganzen Zug gebrüllt hat. Zum Glück war es ein rumänischer Zug und kein ICE, so dass die Leute uns nicht verstanden haben. Solche Streit sind schnell analysiert, weil es relativ einfache Situationen sind. Da war die Schuldfrage so leicht zu klären.
Das machst du jedes Mal. Da wird irgendwie so, ja ich stehe im Zug und der Papsi schreit mich plötzlich an. Wir sind 28 Stunden durch Halbosteuropa gefahren, sind angekommen in einer Stadt und ich wollte einfach nur mal Luft tanken, was essen, was trinken. Und da hast du gesagt, nein, wir haben keine Zeit, wir müssen zum Spiel. Wir haben nur 20 Minuten und müssen in den nächsten Zug. Und ich hatte so eine Halskrause und in dem Zug mussten wir uns beeilen, damit wir den Platz kriegen. Das war der Grund, warum ich auch nicht sofort mit Schimpfworten angefangen habe.
Doch.
Ja, na gut, okay. Das weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Sofort eigentlich.
Da sind halt so Momente, an die kann ich mich auch immer nur sehr schämhaft erinnern.
Ich kann dich da noch gut dran erinnern. Da kann ich deinem Gedächtnis ja auf die Sprünge helfen. Also sowas ist einfach nicht so leicht zu analysieren, weil das nicht besonders kompliziert ist. Und da bin ich auch nicht besonders nachtragend. Anders in solchen Szenen wie die Nudelszene oder so, die halt einfach deutlich komplexer sind. Und bei solchen Dingen, wo es tatsächlich ein Problem gibt, das auch nach dem Streit noch nicht gelöst ist, sondern wo der Streit ein Symptom eines fehlenden Problems war, da ist es dann natürlich nicht ganz so einfach, das dann nachzubearbeiten. Aber das funktioniert dann eigentlich auch mit längerem Abstand natürlich. Eine Sache, die zum Beispiel ein bisschen unrealistisch ist am Film, auch bei dieser Nudelszene, mindestens der Tag, wenn nicht die Woche, sind danach auch gelaufen. Also es funktioniert bei so einem heftigen Meltdown. Läuft es nicht so, dass wir dann die Reise einfach fortsetzen, dass ich sage, ja, blöd gelaufen, dann hole ich mir jetzt woanders was zu essen. Sondern das wird länger nach. Das wird gewissermaßen bis heute nach. Es ist immer noch so, dass ich mich nicht damit abfinden kann, dass diese Nudeln noch nicht gegessen werden konnten. Das wird auch bis an mein Lebensende so bleiben. Das ist nichts, was so schnell beendet ist wie im Film.
Auch bei der Bushaltestellenszene, muss man sagen, im Original.
Ich wäre dann gar nicht zur Schule gegangen.
Aber ihr streitet jetzt nicht anders. Weil ihr so oft schon quasi ein Drehbuch vor euren Streit überarbeitet habt. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sich manchmal denkt, ah Moment mal, dieses Schimpfwort habe ich doch das letzte Mal rausredigiert. Vielleicht verwende ich es jetzt dann nicht.
Nein, das Schöne ist ja, was auf jeden Fall an, dass es uns gelingt ist, zwar mit sehr harten Worten zu streiten, oder es ist ja eigentlich gar kein Streiten mehr, es fängt ja eigentlich erst mal mit massiven Beschimpfungen an, bevor wir streiten. Das ist ja eigentlich so eine andere Herangehensweise. Aber es ist schon schön, dass wir bei den Schimpfworten trotzdem sehr achtsam sind. Also das finde ich ist gut gelungen. Aber heute, ob wir heute anders streiten? Also wir streiten weniger, würde ich sagen, auf jeden Fall. Das würde ich sagen. Es gibt also viele Dinge, wo wir vielleicht auch beide irgendwie gar keine Kraft haben, uns über irgendwelche Kleinigkeiten wirklich zu streiten. Wobei, was ist eine Kleinigkeit? Das kann dann schon wieder in der Beurteilung schnell mal zu einem Streit führen.
Aber das würde mich, also wenn es für euch in Ordnung ist, dann würde ich ganz gerne noch so ein bisschen allgemeiner mit euch sprechen, was eben einfach jetzt passiert ist seit dem letzten Tribünengespräch. Da habe ich mir nämlich die Frage gestellt, Jason, ist es für dich eine Erleichterung, dass dich jetzt die, die Umgebung endlich so sieht, wie du ja immer dich schon gefühlt hast, nämlich als Erwachsenen?
Paradoxerweise nicht immer. Also für mich persönlich hat sich ja tatsächlich wenig verändert. Ja, es gibt seitdem ich, also seitdem ich neun bin, gibt es Familienvereinbarungen, die mir endlich alle Rechte zugeschrieben hat, die ich, die man sonst mit 18 so erhält. Und das Einzige, was sich wirklich verändert, ist das Wahlrecht. Und ja, Landtagswahl in meinem Bundesland, wobei ich da auch nicht so richtig Bock drauf habe, sondern das als Pflicht sehe. Ich bin wirklich angekommen, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist so das Einzige, was sich verändert hat. Ansonsten ist es tatsächlich so, dass es an einigen Stellen auch schwieriger geworden ist, weil ich nicht einsehe, dass nur dadurch, dass ich älter werde, also ein rein passives Geschehen, auf das ich keinen Einfluss habe, plötzlich andere Erwartungen an mich gesetzt werden. Meine Selbstständigkeit zum Beispiel hat sich in den letzten fünf, sechs Jahren nicht verändert und auch nicht erhöht. Aber das scheinen alle Menschen irgendwie von mir zu erwarten, wenn ich älter werde. Das möchte ich aber auch gar nicht. Also das ist nichts, woran ich irgendwie scheitere, sondern das ist einfach etwas, was ich nicht für erstrebenswert halte. Und es gibt anscheinend in unserer Gesellschaft und in unserer Kultur ein recht starres, lineares Verständnis des Aufwachsens und was man dann irgendwann in einem bestimmten Alter so erfüllen muss. Und das möchte ich halt in ganz vielen Punkten nicht erfüllen und erfülle es auch einfach nicht. Und deswegen, vor ein paar Jahren war es dann praktisch, dass Menschen mich wie ein Kind behandelt haben und ich das nicht wollte. Und ich mich ständig weigern musste, praktisch als Kind bezeichnet zu werden. Heute bezeichnet mich sogar niemand mehr als Kind. Aber es knüpft Menschen, knüpfen plötzlich Dinge ans Erwachsensein, mit dem ich nicht einverstanden bin. Und mit dem ich mich auch nicht beugen werde, weil ich nicht einsehe, wieso ich mich mit einem anderen Verständnis, das ohne logische Argumente kommt, also es ist ja nicht so, dass Menschen zu mir kommen und sagen, hier, das ist so und so aus dem und dem guten Grund, dann lasse ich mich auch immer gerne überzeugen, ob wenn Menschen einfach nur sagen, ja du bist jetzt 18, deswegen ist das so. Nee. Und deswegen, es sind andere Probleme als vor fünf Jahren, aber es ist gar nicht so viel einfacher geworden.
Und magst du ein Beispiel geben für so eine Erwartungshaltung, die an dich herangetragen wird, die du nicht erfüllen möchtest?
Also das Thema der Selbstständigkeit ist sicherlich eins. Ich bin jetzt in der 13. Klasse und irgendwie scheint es ein normales, also scheint es normal zu sein, dass man jetzt irgendwie nach der Schule dann irgendwann bei den Eltern auszieht. Und ich möchte das gar nicht. Ich möchte, dass das so bleibt, wie es ist. Und das fällt irgendwie Menschen, also an einigen Menschen anscheinend, schwer zu akzeptieren. Oder das Thema Fahrerlaubnis, die ich nicht haben möchte aus verschiedenen Gründen. Gilt anscheinend auch so als so ein Meilenstein zum Erwachsenwerden, irgendwie, was ich nicht so ganz verstehe. Oder auch das Thema romantische Beziehungen, woran ich einfach gar kein Interesse habe und wo ich auch keine keine Anziehung verspüre, ist auch etwas, wo man was irgendwie in unserer Kultur scheinbar als Bedingungen für das Erlangen von Reife zählt. Und ohne jegliches, also ohne jegliche logische Begründung einfach aus der Geschichte heraus erwachsen. Und da verstehe ich halt nicht, wieso ich mich da einstehe. Also ich verstehe es nicht, sondern ich weigere mich, mich dort einfach einzufügen.
Und wie ist das für dich, Mirco? Es war ja so, dass, also Jason hatte immer schon diese unglaubliche Rhetorik vom Hirnschmalz dahinter, ganz zu schweigen. Das hört man in der, also die höheren Autore können sich nochmal das Tribünengespräch von 2019 anhören. Da hört man das und bei euch im Podcast konnte man das ja schon viel länger mitverfolgen. Und dennoch ist dieser Mensch ja einfach gewachsen und älter geworden. Und irgendwann bekommt man auch das physische Aussehen eines Erwachsenen. Was hat sich denn für dich verändert in den letzten Jahren?
Also A hat sich bei mir erstmal verändert, dass ich auch weiter lernen musste. Also dieses Thema Erwartungshaltung gegen ihn gegenüber. Ja, das ist auch bei mir so, dass ich eine andere Erwartungshaltung an meinen 18-jährigen Sohn habe als an meinen 7-jährigen. Und das ist für mich auch immer wieder so ein Lernprozess an der ein oder anderen Stelle. Wir waren jetzt, letzte Woche gab es diesen, waren wir ja bei Stern TV, da gibt es so eine kleine Szene in Elbersberg, wie ich eigentlich so von wegen Luftblase, sondern eigentlich ganz selbstverständlich von ihm erwarte. Okay, wenn wir jetzt da nicht durchgehen können, ja dann sag mir Bescheid, wenn wir weitergehen können, weil ich schon wieder so eine Halskrause hatte irgendwie so. Und dass auch die Zündschnur, egal wie sehr man sich vornimmt, ich meine in dem Moment, wenn man so überlegt, okay das ist jetzt so einer unserer total wichtigen Medienauftritte und trotzdem ist etwas, wo du dann, wenn du da so drinnen bist, so mit allem drum und dran, einfach diese kurze Zündschnur so da ist und da gelingt es auch weiterhin keinem anderen Menschen so ziel sich eine kleine Zündschnur dann auch die Lunde zum Brennen zu bringen.
Ist denn die Zündschnur wirklich so klein?
Ich denke, ja, das weiß Andreas aber auch, oder nicht?
Ja, also wir in unserem Zusammenhang haben wir keine kurze Zündschnur gehabt bislang, oder?
Ja, Moment mal, aber wir kennen ja auch...
Über was sprechen wir jetzt?
Wir kennen jetzt ja auch noch Collini Su, der ja quasi hinter Mirco steht. Deswegen möchte ich das doch so ganz leicht in Frage stellen. Das ist ja eigentlich der eigentliche Wahnsinn, dass man das raushalten konnte aus dem Film.
Das finde ich allerdings auch und das finde ich sehr schade übrigens.
Dass man was genau aus dem Film raushalten kann.
Collini Su ist der vorherige Bezeichnung des Twitter-Accounts, der auch in seiner gesamten Ausrichtung, in seiner Tonalität dir sicherlich in großen Teilen gefallen hätte, aber schon ein bisschen anders war.
Aber gibt es die Tweets dann jetzt noch unter Wochenendrebell?
Die gibt es zum Teil, nicht alle. Da sind sehr, sehr viele weg.
Aber die sind gar nicht mehr da, oder?
Ein paar sehr schöne habe ich als Screenshot tatsächlich noch da. Insbesondere ein paar Reaktionen, die kann ich dir dann zeigen.
Was dein Vater gerade dir vorgeworfen hat, dass du angeblich immer so genau seine Zündchen gefunden hättest, das hat dein Vater bei ganz, ganz vielen Fußballfans gemacht. Dass er, egal welches Vereins, bevorzugt aber Bayern-Fans, so genau an die schmerzhafte Stelle hingetwittert hat und sich dann völlig erstaunt gezeigt hat, dass Menschen sich darüber ärgern.
Also Trolling. Ja, das war Trolling. Aber das war halt auch oft Trolling weit über die üblichen Trolling-Grenzen hinaus. Das brauche ich dir nicht sagen. Da bin ich heute noch sehr, sehr dankbar, dass wir überhaupt hier sein können. Weil ich auch dich ganz persönlich erinnere, ja. Da ging es deinen Kindern schlecht. Und da habe ich irgendeinen wirklich... Auch spät nachts hast du dann irgendwas getweetet, weil ich glaube, deine Kinder waren die ganze Zeit gebrochen. Du hast dir echt Sorgen gemacht. Und irgendwas habe ich dann irgendwie so... Ich würde auch kotzen, wenn mein Vater bei anfallen würde. Das war so ein klassischer Kulinissus, würde ich mal so sagen. Die Reaktion kam sehr prompt, aber in der klassischen Max-Ost-Manier. Also wirklich sehr höflich, aber bestimmt wirklich. Und es war etwas, was mich seit Jahren immer wieder beschäftigt, dass ich sage, Mensch, dass der Max eigentlich noch so mit dir spricht, so nach der Situation.
War ich da wirklich noch höflich? Ja.
Höflich aber bestimmt. Du hast mir sehr deutlich mitgeteilt, dass du es nicht in Ordnung findest. Aber das war jetzt nicht so, wie Jason jetzt mal so reagieren würde in der Eskalation. Du kamst ohne Schimpfworte, klar.
Das ist ja faszinierend. Na gut, dann kann es ja ganz so schlimm dann doch nicht gewesen sein.
Gegenüber ASV-Fans hat er sich nie in irgendeiner Weise schlecht verhalten. Das kann ich glaube ich sagen. Da war das Auftreten dann auch langweilig.
Ja, ihr liegt ja schon da unten. Da war dann nicht mehr viel. Ich glaube, das war schon immer so ein bisschen eine FC Bayern Problematik. Das ist auch einfacher natürlich. Das kommt ja dazu. War aber auch im Film dann schade, weil im Film tatsächlich noch so ein, zwei Bayern-Passagen rausgeschnitten wurden. Ich hoffe auf die Outtakes. Da setze ich drauf, dass die da vielleicht noch zum Tragen kommen. Weil da kam das eigentlich auch so ein bisschen durch. Und vielleicht ist das dann auch so ein bisschen, das zeigt, dass ich damit nicht ganz alleine bin. Bei zwei Premieren gab es oft Szenenapplaus. Aber der Moment, wenn der FC Bayern durchgestrichen wird, war tatsächlich so der überraschendste Moment für mich. Wo wir unglaublich, also insbesondere in Essen gut Nähe zum BVB vielleicht, da gab es Standing Ovations während des Films insgesamt. Es war sehr skurril.
Also weil Bayern eben nicht der Lieblingsverein von Jason wird. Was natürlich noch mal eine nachträgliche Niederlage ist für den Verlagsmitarbeiter damals, der das euch, der zweite, glaube ich, der zuständig war für das Buch, der gesagt hat, das Ende müssen wir ändern, kommt doch nach München und dann wird er einfach Bayern fällen. Da bin ich gespannt, was ihr dann morgen bei der Premiere hier in München erlebt. Das mussten wir dann im Nachhinein noch mal sagen. Jason, wie ist denn bei dir noch die Situation weitergegangen? Also du bist jetzt in der 13. Klasse, das hast du gesagt. Was ist der Stand bei deinem Forschungsprojekt, das habe ich mich gefragt. Dein Buch ist ja schon lange erschienen, das war ja schon vor Corona. Aber wie ist da der Stand?
Ich mache das jetzt seit sieben Jahren und es ist immer noch die Chaos-Theorie, aber mittlerweile bin ich so weit, ich habe ja in den Corona-Jahren online an internationalen Wettbewerben teilgenommen und bin jetzt praktisch dabei, also aktuell in einer sehr theoretischen Phase des Projektes, wo ich so ein mathematisches Erklärungsmodell praktisch untersuche und es ist viel einfach rechnen und simulieren und nachdenken. Es ist praktisch zu mehr geworden, als es eigentlich ursprünglich gedacht war, ein bisschen wie unsere Reisen auch.
Aber geht es noch um das Pendel, an dem ein Pendel hängt?
Das war der Anfang des Projekts mit der Chaos-Theorie, dieses Chaos-Pendel, wo man eben zwei Pendel aneinander hängt und dann zeigt sich chaotisches Verhalten. An diesem Pendel ist es mittlerweile gar nicht mehr möglich, meine Forschungsfragen zu untersuchen, weil die Präzision nicht mehr genügt. Und weil es wirklich um etwas Grundlegendes geht. Es geht wirklich um den fundamentalen Aufbau von chaotischen Systemen und die Ursachen dafür, warum sie sich so verhalten, wie sie sich verhalten. Das heißt, es reicht nicht mehr einfach zu messen, wie sie sich verhalten, sondern ich will den tiefer liegenden Grund wissen. Und dafür benötigt es eben sehr abstrakte Erklärungen. Das ist so der aktuelle Stand. Und aktuell ist das ein bisschen in geringerem Umfang. Vielleicht noch einmal die Woche, sodass ich mich tatsächlich damit beschäftige, weil so viele Termine für Wochenendrebellen anliegen. Und das ist dann eher praktisch so eine Art Auszeit, wenn man dann keine Termine für Wochenendrebellen hat, zu sinnieren und nachzudenken über Dinge, über die ich auch sonst noch nachdenke. Und tatsächlich sind diese grundlegenden Fragen zum Aufbau der Welt auch die Dinge, über die ich sonst eigentlich so nachdenke, wenn mein Kopf mal frei ist. Und deswegen, das Forschungsprojekt ist mittlerweile fast so eine Art Freizeitbeschäftigung im Vergleich zu Schule und halt zu den Terminen, die wir so wahrnehmen.
Was muss denn passieren, also wenn du sagen möchtest, was muss denn passieren, dass dein Kopf frei sein kann?
Ich glaube, in letzter Zeit war es relativ selten der Fall. Aber mein Kopf ist frei, wenn er zu arbeiten hat. Wenn in meinem Kopf es arbeitet, wenn ich sehe, Dinge funktionieren so, wie sie funktionieren sollten. Jetzt auf den Premieren zum Beispiel, war mein Kopf tatsächlich frei. Oder auf Zugfahrten, wenn ich davon höre, dass Dinge erledigt werden. Wenn Papst mir sagt, das ist erledigt worden, das ist erledigt worden, das hat so geklappt, dann ist mein Kopf mal kurz frei. Ein freier Kopf ist für mich nicht ein leerer Kopf. Das ist ein bisschen ein Missverständnis, das häufig passiert. Wenn ich zuhause bin und alles ein bisschen unklar ist, es geht nicht voran, dann wirkt das von außen vielleicht statisch und ruhig, weil ich da nur liege. Aber in Wahrheit bin ich gerade so unruhig, wie man nur sein kann. Das geht überhaupt nicht. Die Momente, wo viele meinen, das muss doch gerade rasen in deinem Kopf, auf der Bühne, auf der Premiere in Berlin oder in Essen, als wir der Applaus kamen, das waren Szenen, also Momente purer Entspannung.
Das ist faszinierend. Stimmt es doch noch, eine Frage zum Film, die ich mir gestellt habe. Wie nah ist das Kinderzimmer des Films Jason an deinem Kinderzimmer?
Es ist näher daran an meinem heutigen Zimmer als in meinem Kinderzimmer. Aber grundsätzlich, also ich glaube, es war ja sogar jemand, der sich mein Zimmer angeschaut hat da, richtig? Der hat halt mein aktuelles Zimmer gesehen, so wie es jetzt ist. Und es passt schon, also das, was wir dort so mitgegeben haben als Botschaften, was sehr gut realisiert wurde, ist, dass es so eine Art geordnetes Chaos ist. Also es liegen viele Dinge so herum und viele Dinge haben wir irgendwie so ihren Platz. Und das ist sehr wimmelig alles. Und das ist auch in der Realität so. Also mein Zimmer, egal wo man hinguckt, der Kopf hat eigentlich irgendwas zum Arbeiten und man kann sich überall irgendwas anschauen, so, dass es so nicht langweilig wird. Aber trotzdem ist es keineswegs so, dass alles so komplett wild herum liegt. Und es hat schon sein System, so, was man vielleicht von außen aber nicht so richtig versteht.
Das habe ich meiner Mama früher auch immer gesagt.
Aber das ist tatsächlich gut getroffen und ist das erste und einzige Mal in unserem gesamten Leben. Also wir hatten jetzt auch bei den Medienterminen oft Anfragen, so Home-Story drehen oder sonstiges. Und wir haben immer gesagt, hey, wir machen uns schon nackig im Buch, wir machen uns nackig im Film. Es muss so einen Ort geben, wo so niemand ist, außer Menschen, die uns sehr, sehr nahe stehen. Und die einzige Ausnahme, die wir gemacht haben, ist, dass wir das Bühnenteam quasi für den Film gesagt haben, okay, ihr könnt einmal kommen, weil die gesagt haben, du musst uns das erklären. Wie macht ihr das irgendwie, wenn da so ein Schnipsel Haare irgendwie und dann wird das aufgehoben im Beutel? Und wie sieht Jason's Zimmer aus? Und sie konnten halt die große Erinnerungswand, die war ihnen wichtig, die gab es zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie da waren, gar nicht mehr, weil es einfach so viel wurde, dass wir gesagt haben, wir packen das jetzt mal alles schön ein bisschen sortiert in Kisten. Aber ich finde, sie haben den so eigentlich wie auch bei der Geschichte, dass man immer so am Anfang gesagt hat, das muss so irgendwo diesen Kern treffen, ohne dass es eins zu eins passt. Und ich glaube, das ist in meinem Zimmer so auch ganz gut gelungen.
Ja, aber das habe ich mich nämlich gefragt, weil es eben doch ein bisschen wimmelig ist. Aber Jason, da bist du mir und meinem Ordnungssystem auch sehr nahe. Ich werde euch mein Arbeitszimmer nicht zeigen, dass es über uns liegt. Aber da sieht es ganz ähnlich aus. Und sobald ich mal aufräume, findet man absolut nichts mehr. Jetzt haben wir im Grunde euch ja über eine ganz lange Zeit schon begleiten dürfen. Ich meine, Andreas ja auch. Erst über Twitter, dann über das Blog, das Buch, jetzt der Film. Was kommt denn als nächstes?
Also da gibt es noch viel, was ich so im Kopf habe.
Das dachte ich mir nämlich.
Als allerallernächstes, also in sehr naher Zukunft, kommt eine Fortsetzung des Buches. Das ist ein zweiter Teil. Wo es praktisch um die Erlebnisse nach 2016 geht, um all das, was wir noch erlebt haben, um unsere Osteuropa-Tour, über die wir dann mal ausführlich erzählen, über unsere Lesereise, auch über mein Forschungsprojekt, über die Familienvereinbarungen, über die Presse- und Medientermine, die wir so wahrgenommen haben, über Leute, mit denen wir in den Stadion gefahren sind, unseren Ausflug nach Glasgow und wirklich alles, was wir so erlebt haben zwischen 2016 und 2020. Diesmal in dialogischer und paritätischer Form. Wir schreiben 50-50 und dadurch kommt unsere Streitkultur auch im Buch zum Tragen. Wir widersprechen uns dann auch in unseren Kapiteln so. Unsere Regel war praktisch so, wir funken uns nicht dazwischen und verbieten uns, über die andere Person zu schreiben. Aber man muss immer mit der Reaktion der anderen Person rechnen, dann im eigenen Kapitel. Eigentlich schreiben wir über dieselben Erlebnisse, aber manchmal liest es sich gar nicht wie dieselben Erlebnisse.
Also ist es ein bisschen wie auf euren Lesungen eigentlich, oder?
Ja, davon ist es ein bisschen inspiriert. Das ist Wochenendrebellen, Chaos auf Augenhöhe. Und das wird noch dieses Jahr erscheinen. Das ist also für die nahe Zukunft. Und dann, wir haben ja auch jetzt auf der Premierenlesung, praktisch mit diesem Buch an meinem 18. Geburtstag, haben wir ja auch unsere Spendenziele wieder erhöht für die Welfare in Evans Abbotts Stiftung, wo wir für Trinkwasserversorgung und sanitäre Anlagen sammeln, die nachhaltig zu errichten. Dieses erhöhte Spendenziel muss ja auch noch irgendwie erst mal wieder erreicht werden, von 100.000 Euro jetzt. Auch das steht dann, also es sollte schneller gehen mit den ersten 50.000 eigentlich. Deswegen steht das in naher Zukunft noch an. Und dann gibt es noch ein paar weitere Pläne, aber die sind noch so in der Konzertphase.
Aber das heißt, das Buch wird jetzt dann noch 2023 erscheinen?
Ja, das sollte eigentlich seit 14 Tagen schon erhältlich sein. Wir haben uns zeitlich ein wenig verschätzt und haben dann gesagt, okay, jetzt mit Biegen und Brechen das irgendwie, egal wie, oder doch jetzt dann in Ruhe die Zeit nochmal nehmen können, um an den letzten Feinheiten auch arbeiten zu können. Wir sind jetzt in der... Lektorat ist durch, wir haben eigentlich soweit alles eingearbeitet, aber wir machen halt, also wir machen das nicht mit dem Verlag, sondern wir machen das ähnlich wie bei Traumschiff Erde, dass wir sagen, okay, das Hardcover kommt als Crowdfunding, weil Jason einen Anspruch hat, wo halt auch viele Verlage dann sagen, sorry, also da wird es für uns dann schwierig gegebenenfalls so ein bisschen. Und die Zeit werden wir uns im Oktober nehmen, aber ich denke, dass das Crowdfunding wahrscheinlich sogar in den nächsten 14 Tagen oder so schon starten kann oder so.
Dann wird dieser Link nachträglich auf jeden Fall in den Shownotes zu finden gewesen sein. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn ihr den jetzt noch nicht habt, dann schaut in ein paar Wochen nochmal vorbei. Dann gibt es auf jeden Fall einen Link zu diesem Crowdfunding. Das heißt, es geht munter weiter. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, was von euch noch zu sehen sein wird. Ich weiß nicht, Andreas, ob du noch Fragen an die beiden hast, bevor wir dann hier sie so langsam entlassen auf ihrem Promo-Tour-Marathon.
Nee, momentan nicht. Und das, was du gerade gesagt hast, Promo-Tour-Marathon. Wir sind jetzt auch eine Dreiviertelstunde dabei. Jetzt überlassen wir den anderen auch noch die Fragen. Ich hoffe, dass wir nicht allzu viele Fragen hatten, die ihr schon 530 Mal beantworten mussten.
Nein, ganz und gar nicht. Ich habe es vorhin dem Max ganz kurz im Vorgespräch gesagt, das ist natürlich auch immer total angenehm, ähnlich wie mit Mara letzte Woche oder so. Das ist halt ein anderes Setup für uns, als wenn du dort bei Stern TV sitzt und sagst, was sagt der Sohn jetzt, was sagt der Sohn jetzt? Ich habe da keine Angst bei ihm insgesamt, aber es ist schon ein Thema. Und beim Rasenfunk war es halt doppelt besonders, weil ich habe es dem Max irgendwann per SMS geschrieben, dass wenn wir uns das nächste Mal sehen, und das ist tatsächlich heute nach ganz langer Zeit der Fall, ich ihm dann auch noch verrate, was der Rasenfunk mit dem Film zu tun hatte. Denn es gab tatsächlich eine Drehbuchversion, wo auch der Rasenfunk noch drin war an sich. Hat es nicht bis ins Finale geschafft, insgesamt leider, was uns wirklich traurig macht. Aber es gab so einen kompletten Handlungsstrang, wo es eigentlich auch um die Gründung von Jasons Podcast ging und wie wichtig ihm Podcasten ist. Richard fand den Ansatz ganz spannend, diese Form von Kommunikation, die ja dann im ersten Schritt auch erstmal nur so sehr einseitig ist, das so ein bisschen zu beleuchten. Und um dann dieses Thema Podcasting durchzubringen, gab es so zwei Stellen, wo dann auch andere Podcasts eine kleine Rolle spielen. Und in der damaligen Version ging es um einen Besuch auf der Süd. Und wo ich den Jason dann frage, wo er will zu wissen, dass die Süd so eine Tribüne ist, wie die Tribüne ist. Und das entgegnet Jason dann in der damaligen Version, dass er das im Rasenfunk gehört hat. Und wir haben dann überlegt, wer könnte der Gast im Rasenfunk gesehen haben? Und wir haben uns dann für den Namen Malte sogar entschieden, weil wir gedacht haben, es gibt einen Malte im nordrhein-westfälischen Raum, der immer sehr, sehr kritisch ist.
Der wäre aber nie im Rasenfunk. Der hasst alles, was ich tue.
Ich weiß, deswegen habe ich gesagt, wenn das der Malte im Rasenfunk gesagt hätte. Und leider ist aber diese komplette Podcast-Sequenz, das war ihnen dann doch eine Spur zu viel, insgesamt, weil es so viele Handlungsstränge gibt. Haben wir sehr bedauert, aber es funktioniert halt leider nicht immer alles.
Vielleicht ein Teil zwei.
Aber der Bonus-Content auf der DVD-Werb wird sehr interessant werden.
Das könnte interessant sein, wenn oder... Ich meine, man weiß es ja nie, was so alles noch passiert. Aber auch ein Teil zwei ist natürlich jetzt, nicht davon abhängig, hätten wir noch was zu erzählen, sondern er wäre tatsächlich insgesamt nur davon abhängig, wie erfolgreich wird Wochenendrebellen Teil eins. Das ist so jetzt die Tage, wo wir Regentänze aufführen werden und sonstiges, um einen guten Start am Wochenende hinzukriegen.
Das ist jetzt schon das zweite Mal, dass etwas knapp in einem Kinofilm nicht vorkommt vom Rasenfunk. Ich hatte mal ein Cameo in der Serie, darf ich das jetzt inzwischen sagen? Inzwischen darf ich das glaube ich sagen, Gute Freunde, die jetzt rauskommen über den FC Bayern in den 70ern. Da habe ich einen Reporter gespielt. Und ich sage es mal so, nachdem ich, also ich war da eben vor Ort und hatte dann so zwei, drei Zeilen Text und so weiter, und nachdem ich nie wieder was von denen gehört habe und auch nicht zur Premiere eingeladen wurde, was mir noch voll und munich versprochen wurde, gehe ich davon aus, diese Szene wird es nicht in die Serie geschafft haben. Eigentlich bin ich mir sogar sicher. Ja, müsst ihr halt dann damit leben, dass das einzige Vorkommen des Rasenfunks in einer großen Produktion dann in der Bayern-Doku ist auf Amazon Prime. Da kommt der Rasenfunk vor. Das ist auch nicht, was ich davon halten soll, aber...
Manchmal sind es halt auch die Zufälle. Vielleicht so als letzte kleine Anekdote, weil das ganz spannend ist, was auf der Essen-Premiere Joachim Kohl hat mein Dad kennengelernt an dem Abend. Das war natürlich mega emotional. Ich hatte dann gesagt, Mensch, wie war das eigentlich mit dem Fansein Borussia Dortmund? Wie eng ist das so? Allein die Frage war schon ein großes Problem. Aber es kam dann raus, dass es tatsächlich so war, wie ich befürchtet hatte. Wir haben irgendwann mal einen Anruf bekommen, und da hieß es, ihr seid ja so darauf hinterher, dass das alles authentisch ist. Und dein Papa ist ja eigentlich Anhänger von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Meinst du, da bestünde die Möglichkeit, dass wir dort Anpassungen vornehmen? Und mein Dad damals so recht laissez faire, so naja, ist egal eigentlich. Und jetzt hat sich herausgestellt, dass das tatsächlich mit einer, nicht eine Bedingung von Joachim Kohl war, aber er sofort gesagt hat, na gut, wenn der Vater Schalke Fan ist, dann könnt ihr es vergessen. Und fand ich total sympathisch. Und auch während der gesamten Premiere, ich saß in Essen bei der Premiere und Publikumspremiere ist dann tatsächlich, das war uns nicht bewusst auch rein stimmungstechnisch noch mal was völlig anderes. Und wie Joachim Kohl, der an dem Abend den Film dann auch auf der Leinwand das erste Mal saß, da so saß und bei jeder BVB-Szene wieder so abgegangen ist mit allen Drohen dran. Es ist wirklich ein unglaublicher Typ. Und ich hätte es im Nachgang, habe ich so ganz, ganz häufig, diese kleine Angst seit Dienstag. Was ist, wenn du damals gesagt hättest, nee, also mein Papa ist Fortuna-Fan, ich hätte dann schon auch gerne, dass das im Film so ist, dann wäre uns Joachim Kohl mehr oder weniger durch die Lappen gegangen, was ich mir, wenn ich es dann irgendwann erfahren hätte, niemals verziehen würde.
Siehst du denn nicht, was deine Liebe zu Fortuna alles kaputt macht?
Aber schließt sich da nicht da ein Kreis hier? Am Anfang geht es darum, den Verein zu finden, und am Ende geht es darum, ja, also so schlimm ist es nicht, wenn er jetzt einen anderen Fan darstellt. Und dann sagt Joachim Kohl, also Schalke-Fan sollte er bitte nicht sein.
Der hat auch schon tatsächlich Rollen abgelehnt deswegen. Das war sehr, sehr skurril. Wir waren dann noch zusammen beim BVB-Screening. Also wir haben ja alle Bundesliga-Vereine, erste, zweite, dritte Liga wurden angeschrieben von Agentur, um inwieweit sie den Film unterstützen. Und es gab total viele Rückmeldungen. Und dann waren wir bei einem BVB-Sonderscreening mit ihm zusammen eingeladen, wo wir einfach so ein bisschen über den Film sprechen. Und ich hatte ein blaues Hemd an. Er hat mich angeguckt, dieser Mann, der sonst eigentlich, der kann ja nicht böse gucken oder so. Also den guckst du ja wirklich an und dann nimmst du dem ja diese Gutmütigkeit, die ist ihm ja ins Gesicht geschrieben. Aber das war so ein Moment, wo ich dann gedacht habe, wo kriegst du jetzt noch mal andere Klamotten her, um aus diesem blauen Hemd rauszukommen, oder? War ein sehr, sehr schöner und sehr, sehr skurriler Moment insgesamt.
Das ist doch schön. Und dann kann ich auch noch an der Stelle verraten, wenn wir jetzt eh so allgemein plaudern. Ich dachte ja erst noch, so toll ich den Film finde, aber muss ich jetzt eine eigene Sendung noch dazu machen, weil ich davon ausgegangen bin, alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer, die kriegen das sowieso mit, die gehen sowieso in diesen Film. So wie ich ja damals, 2019, auch davon ausgegangen bin, alle Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer, die kennen euch schon, deswegen ist es nicht schlimm, dass wir die Folge erst 2019 aufgenommen haben. Aber es war tatsächlich die Rückmeldung aus der Community, deswegen nochmal Danke an dieser Stelle. Es haben mehrere Leute nachgefragt, Mensch, das ist ja toll, und ich habe die euch da, damals habe ich über euch die Wochenendrebellen entdeckt. Und deswegen haben sie sich so gefreut, dann diesen Film zu sehen. Das war für mich wesentlicher Antrieb, das hier nochmal zu machen. Das freut mich total.
Verrückterweise, ich hatte es dir ja am Telefon schon gesagt, war auch keine Bauchpinselei, sehr, sehr häufig eine Rückmeldung, die wir bekommen, dass die Leute nicht sagen, wir kennen euch aus dem Buch, oder wir kennen euch das oder das, sondern wir kennen euch aus dem Rasenfunk insgesamt. Und passt aber dahingehend, ich kann nur allen nahelegen, gegebenenfalls, man kann ja auch so schlecht zum Film verlinken, aber wer auch immer irgendwo mal gegebenenfalls Unsinn über die Wochenendrebellen liest, Tribünengespräch verlinken ist sicherlich dort immer ein guter Weg, um wieder so ein bisschen nah an die Realität dran zu kommen.
Weil ihr euch aber damals so viel Zeit genommen habt, das liegt ja nicht am Rasenfunk, sondern es liegt an euch, schon immer war es so, dass der Rasenfunk auf den Schultern seiner Gäste steht. Und das sind in dem Fall unter anderem die Schultern von Andreas Thies. Andreas, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du hier warst, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du uns exklusiv, meine Güte, das habe ich total unterverkauft, exklusive O-Töne hast du uns mitgebracht. Danke dir, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Und natürlich herzlichen Dank, Mirco und Jason von Juterczenka. Ich wünsche euch allen Erfolg der Welt und aber vor allem, dass ihr weiter... Also wenn du sagst, Jason, dass das gerade so mit die glücklichste Zeit für dich ist, dann bereitet mir das unglaubliche Freude und dann wünsche ich euch beiden einfach, dass ich diese Zeit so lange verlängern möge, in welcher Ausprügung auch immer, wie es möglich ist. Ganz herzlichen Dank euch, dass ihr hier wart.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt allein crowdfinanziert. Wir haben hier viele Crowdfinanzierungsfreunde in dieser Runde. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Alle Informationen zum Film, der am Donnerstag, den 28. September starten wird, werdet ihr natürlich in den Show notes finden. Genauso wie noch Links zum Tribünengespräch. Und dann danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke für euer Feedback, das wir bestimmt hierauf erhalten. Und dann habt eine gute Zeit und bleibt gesund. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.